now i'm talking about the harsh
realities of the assemblies
and how the brewing graphs face these
realities during the course
of the discussion we have made some
ridiculous unrealistic assumptions like
we assume that we have perfect coverage
of the journal by reads
that means at each position on the
genome we have
a read generated at that position
secondly we assume that greeds are
error-free
thirdly we assume that multiplicity of
k-mers are known
and also we assume the distance between
reads
within read pairs were known exactly
but in reality these assumptions
do not hold we don't have
perfect coverage of genome by reads
reads
are error prone the multiplicity of
cameras are
not known either the distance between
reads within read pairs
are inexact and there are many others
problems
but let's go to the first unrealistic
assumption birthing coverage
here we have the genome on the top and
here are the four reads
clearly that we don't have the perfect
coverage in this case
and violates the k assumption of the
diploin graph
so what you can do is to break the reeds
into shorter k-mers
and after this operation the
key assumption of the brewing graph
holds
what is next about the erroneous
greed this is an erroneous trees
by breaking erroneous greed into a
series
of chemos we also generate
phones cameras
and how these phones came and appears in
the graph
well if cameras were exact
then for any
region of the genome that the brewing
graph would look like this
but when we introduce incorrect k-mer
into the graph
we create purple imagine
for an assembly data set usually we have
millions of incorrect cameras
and they forms a lot of bubbles
so the challenge here is to find
out how the genome travers this graph
depicted by the color lines researchers
have developed algorithms
for removing these purples
and simplify the graph but should the
graph looks very simple after this step
well this is the graph of bacterial
genome after simplification
and now it is time
us and answer the question who are these
people
pavel are you still here yes okay can
you answer the question
so these people are not criminals
these are scientists and entrepreneurs
who made their genomes available
a few years ago and started the
personalized genomics revolution
and today this personalized genome
sequencing efforts are in full bloom
and we will soon expand sequencing to
millions of individuals
at the same time there are efforts to
sequence thousands of genomes
and we will soon have nearly all
mammalian genomes for example
sequence simultaneously with
enormous effort to sequence cancer
genomes and understand
what changes in the genome lead to
cancer
and at the heart of this genomics
revolutions
are bioinformaticians like sean who has
been working for two decades now
to develop new algorithmic ideas for
genome sequencing you may ask why in the
world we started
by making some ridiculous assumptions
that sean had to address
in the last segment of this uh
presentation
so was a good reason for this without
this assumption we wouldn't be able to
present
the main ideas of existing
genome sequencing algorithm and that's
actually a common sent
in bioinformatics to simplify the
problem to the point that it becomes
ridiculous solve this problem which
means to develop the key idea for
solving ridiculous problem
and then overcome some ridiculous
assumptions something that sean
described in the last
segment